as Donna said I'm Robert Kasdan senior
executive vice president and we thought
what we would do this morning is I would
ask my three colleagues a set of
questions and then we would turn the
discussion over to you so that you could
follow up on the questions that were
asked to ask totally different questions
before I do that let me just take a
moment to thank all of you who have
worked so hard to get this association
to where it is it makes a very important
difference to those of us working in the
university because it gives us a sense
of connection to the outside world and
it reinforces the sense that the way
we're spending our days really does
matter to people so thank you very much
and a particular thanks to Jim because
Jim not only has provided
extraordinarily leadership extraordinary
leadership to this organization but we
are really excited to have him on the
board of trustees and share the energy
and frankly judgment that he's brought
to this organization with the university
as a whole so thank you one of the
unique characteristics of alumni as they
intersect with the university is their
sense of having taken the long view if
you talk to students history started the
day they arrived faculty have a whole
web of connections to the University
alums from the can look at the
University from the day they arrived
perhaps decades ago to the day that
we're talking I thought it would be
worth noting as we start that the group
of people up on the stage here have a
collective 55 years of experience at
Columbia University so at a time where
job change is actually fairly high over
the last decade or so there's an
enormous amount of stability and I'd be
remiss if I didn't say most of it is
with Joe and Susan